Michelle yes where are you from where
you grew up New Orleans Louisiana New
Orleans yes sir tell me about your
family growing up you had both your mom
and dad I went to my mom I was adopted
by my grandmother
because my real mother she she abused me
as a baby
I had a broken nose and broken arm
broken a rope before I was six weeks old
and that's pretty much it I was awarded
the state at the age 13.
until 18.
how do you describe your childhood in
general
um
besides abuse at home friendships
outside the home I was happy at home I
was kind of like depressed I wanted to
get away but it is what it is you were
raised by your grandmother my maternal
grandmother and she wasn't as great as
she could have been
she was the I was a momless girl she I
love my mom she was great to me but it
was just my stepfather
I mean you know she didn't know about it
until actually I reported it so it
wasn't her fault what was going on I was
sexually abused from as young as I can
remember until the age 13.
this was in New Orleans yes
then I got awarded staying at 13 until
18.
and at 18 I just I kind of left I didn't
look back
and let them win on my own what'd you do
um pretty much here and there I'm kind
of I guess how you say Gypsy life
traveling a lot I went from Texas to
Mississippi to Alabama to Florida
Georgia
but all in all I ended up getting
married I have three children now
they got adopted out I can't see them
because of what
they say I was an abusive parent but
there was a lot of things that were said
that didn't happen so I'm going to
defend myself on that one I did some
things I shouldn't know but a lot of
things I didn't do but that's what it
was anything you did that may have
warranted drugs that's it but they're
saying I'd get other things like with my
kids not bathe them you know I didn't do
that just a drug part
drug start if you win
um I would say around 11 I started
drinking
I had to act like my mom was an
alcoholic showing two bar rooms I had
access to alcohol all the time
and the heavy drugs started on around
1819 somewhere around there when I
started started meeting men and they
introduced me to them and I got a very
addictive personality it's like when I
when I did heroin I had to go and Chase
and get more and more and more you know
and then finally I just broke off of it
and then now about six years ago I did
the crystal meth and I'm still doing
that
so you went from an opiate
addiction to
getting clean yep and then you picked up
crystal meth yes in my clean part I was
living a really good life I mean my last
car was in Mercedes-Benz you know that's
how good it was I didn't have to work my
husband did you know and then we both
messed up and Bam here we are your kids
are aware now my daughter's in Texas now
but well they're all three grown she got
married she's in Texas and my two boys
are still in Louisiana and they were
raised by their adopted parents no
family they're mine okay Just Once By
the state
I can't well I can't see them right now
but they don't want to see me so what
are your thoughts now on this whole
lifestyle that you
um living now it is what it is I put
myself here nobody nobody did it but me
you know
myself out you're homeless now yes sir
well I'm in a shelter you could consider
that Homeless yes
but um yeah I did it to myself so
I don't blame nobody but me yeah how do
you support yourself
that's funny I can't get food stamps and
I can't get Dr because like I said I'm
going to run from two different states
um so I recycle so you're on the Run
yeah well
pretty much I've been arrested here they
know I'm here but they won't they won't
extradite me unless I go back so you're
gonna run from where Texas and South
Carolina and what were those charges for
Texas is possession less than a gram I
got two years uh read something
probation where like if I do my
probation rate it's automatically wiped
off my record
but at random as soon as I got out of
jail South Carolina is breaking and
entering for five years felony probation
recycling I pretty much dig through
garbage
it's very honest but it's very nasty you
know you can catch things uh you just
don't know what you're putting your
hands on or you find things along the
way too though some good things what
kind of things have you found I found
340 cash money and one dumpster everyone
who tells me recycling that they're
making money recycling always tells me I
found jewelry I found scratch offs I
found Louis Vuitton bags I found 340 in
the cash in a dumpster one day you just
find different things I mean you gotta
know you gotta always with the recycling
you just got to always look it looks
like you tweaking all the time you know
you're not you know like you're on drugs
but you always got to look at the ground
always people drop money you know all
kinds of things jury jumping into a
dumpster to see what's in there has got
to be it is what it is I mean I I got
closed today I messed up so bad that I
wear nothing but for that you know it's
it's nasty I stuck my hand in maggots
before by accident you know uh
of course I get scared I'm a girl you
know I actually almost came in contact
with a rat not too long ago about a
month ago I was in a dumpster and the
rat comes jumping out of the uh
underneath this one garbage bag where I
was at I saw him in time but it was like
that close to me and it was big
but I mean I left that dumpster I didn't
go back
emotionally what is this lifestyle
Duty it's hard I mean at times but like
I said I put myself there so
so you take responsibility yeah of
course I do
if you have dreams of doing things when
you were younger yeah I was gonna be a
nurse I went to school and everything I
messed up
and I um I was actually six weeks away
from graduating becoming a CNA and I
messed myself up
I can't go back do you see that you
messed up or not just the fact that what
happened to you as a younger no I messed
up I got the um felony warrants and what
I was going to do you can't have
felonies on you no but there is maybe
the reason you were on drugs the reason
you messed up it was because I was on
drugs the reason you were on drugs
though could have been because of what
you went through I'm not well people
tell me it has to do with how I was
raised my childhood and everything you
know but I really don't think that's the
reason I'm on drugs I think it's just I
was born with addictive personality my
grandfather he was he he died from
drinking my mom my grandmother died from
drinking you know very addictive people
in my family is that right yeah yeah
my grandfather was a poor boy Cherokee
Grandma used to have to hide the rubbing
alcohol douches anything we'd all call
he drunk and killed him too but he did
alcohol has been a thing for you no
never I mean I partied but it's never
been a big issue for me I can lay it
down
the drugs is the big issue for me
what's your biggest regret my biggest
regret is having children as young as I
did I should have weighed it
I don't regret having them I would have
had them at some point but
I think I could have chose a better
point in my life to have them
to where I could raise them you know
having kids especially when you're not
ready yeah I had my youngest when I was
21. so I mean my oldest are 21. yeah put
you on your heels for the rest of your
life of course it does growing up to
three kids and I had mine all back to
back
all three were in Diapers at one time
so they was constantly I was constantly
having to try to keep them out of
something or you know just running after
them constantly daily
So currently you're using crystal meth
crystal meth yes
what was the hardest part of your life
I don't know there's
I have to say they're all about the same
I mean most people don't go through what
I go through you know not on a normal
everyday life
I met my real mother
that was a big regret you know that was
a
bad part of my life losing my children
you know so they're all pretty much
equal to me
did you feel like you were ever loved
when you were young I know I was loved
yeah about my grandmother I know that
yeah
I don't think my real mother loved me
but I know my grandmother loved me
because I met my role model what's your
biggest fear now
my biggest fear is I'm going through a
mortality thing right now you know the
karma you get what you give uh
um what's going to happen to me because
of what I've done and stuff like that
that's my biggest fear
how was your karma you think
I'm a good person I really am I give the
shirt off my back
but I have done some things too you know
like my children for example
yeah
that's that's my karma
besides that I'm a good person
I beat people I give clothes you know I
don't steal my my business and I don't
mess with people so
to me that's basic parts of life you
know
you talk to your kids at all
I was with my daughter and then she we
had a falling out and we talked since
my boys I've never talked to
not since I lost them yeah
you're always wondering who their mom is
she's one of my son said he didn't
respond
but the way I look at that I tried
that's nothing I could do about that
that's his choice
I did my part as a mother I tried to
contact
I mean I regret he didn't answer but I
can't change it so
I'm not going to dwell on what happened
you know if he doesn't want to answer
that's him
is it hard for a woman on the streets
yeah I would say so we always got men
coming on to us um
we got people stealing from us
there's bullies out there just want to
mess with you for no reason you know
you'd be walking by they don't like how
you look they try to beat you up you
know
even grow men
try to beat you up
but in some aspects it's also easier we
get before men would
you know like food or money
what would you say is your greatest
strength my great strength is I have I'm
caring person
I care what happens to somebody else
yeah you're good nurse huh you'd be a
good nurse I think so if I was able to
finish y'all I was supposed to work with
the elderly
that's why I couldn't go back
do you still have hope for your life of
course how was he I'm 44 I made I made
44 on July 1st
but I I don't believe like suicide and
all that you know I believe I'm here for
a reason I do
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently I would finish school I
would have waited to get married and
have children I would have tried tried
to um if I knew then what I know now I
wouldn't have been around all the bad
people in my life that was around maybe
my life would turn out differently
what was your favorite memory from your
life
um
going to see going to see the movie you
have to move it there everyone more
when I was about seven
the first time I went I saw Honey I
Shrunk the Kids and Roger Rabbit
it's funny how the simplest things yeah
I mean the most
they do
sorry I'm bringing up you you know yeah
I know I'm sorry
Michelle what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life most important lesson is don't
steal from people
because I mean I have stolen before you
know and it got me in jail it got me on
the Run got me you know and it was all
Beyond Drugs That's why I broke into
person's house just stay to yourself
that's my important lesson
you know and if you do anybody does that
they make it
would be a problem
and that's the problem in today's
society people won't keep minding their
own business
they have to get into their neighbor's
business you know and people don't like
that
so
all right Michelle thank you so much for
sharing your story okay she's the best
of luck out here okay thank you